all right let's get into the book here
some things i didn't know about you all
right now this is the most shocking
thing in the whole book okay
kathy has a total crush on fred
and i don't believe it
frank did you know that no god bless you
i wasn't ready until now to express that
i'm more nervous about that than
anything in the book is it true you're
attracted to fred i am attracted to fred
on levels that you wouldn't even
understand it's just as levels you
couldn't understand howard you mean
that's right you mean you find him
attractive as a man i find him
physically attractive and you know i
think that he possesses a beautiful mind
well he's a brilliant guy i don't say no
but he's strange he's weird i don't
think you last two minutes with him
i'm like russell crowe in a beautiful
mind that's the kind of mind that i know
but fred would scare you inside in what
way friends fred's weird he's odd he's
he's a complete i think he's sweet and
sensitive and you don't know how to
handle it that's true that might be that
might be the case but robin what are you
doing
have you ever experimented with him
sexually
absolutely how far have you gone i made
out and i put my finger in his ass see
what it smell like is he a good kisser
yeah she's like a soft kisser
he's soft i've had him on my lap i've uh
no i've i've never experimented with
friends in any way not even accidentally
are you saying you would do for you you
two were in the hotel rooms i slept in a
room in bed i slept in the same bedroom
did you just spoon no i'm not in the
same bed we didn't no no somehow my
imagination your imagination is hazy for
you you wouldn't remember that something
happened
brad you should not have to listen to
this abuse darling i'm going to take you
away from all this no this these are his
fans would you sleep with fred yes
not an issue what you're not getting is
it's not about that with fred it's not
just sexual well it's a connection i
feel a connection you do like this is
relationship stuff this is fresh are you
lying no no i'm not fred's not the type
of guy for one night you take him home